We start out number puzzle by multiplying 5 and 2, which equals 10. 7 is the x
term, so that goes into the bottom. We want to find a factor pair of 10 that
sums to 7. That must be 2 and 5. We can rewrite the 7x as positive 2x and
positive 5x. Now we'll use factoring by grouping to finish out our problem. From
the first two terms I can factor out an x, leaving me with 5x plus 2. The second
two terms are a little bit tricky. They don't share a factor of 5, of x or 2,
but they do share a factor of 1. We can always factor out a 1 if it appears that
two terms do not have common factors. Our final factored form is x plus 1 times
5x plus 2. I want to acknowledge that there's other ways to factor this. You
might have switched the 5x and the 2x and then continued factoring by grouping.
That would work as well. As a quick check on the end, we can do some mental math
to make sure this factored form is equal to this polynomial. X times 5x is 5x
squared, 1 times 5x is 5x. And x times 2 is 2x. If I add 5x and 2x together,
I'll get 7x. And finally, 1 times 2 is positive 2.